hier volodimir Zelenski a tenté de
convaincre les élus récal Citran pour
l'instant en 20 et vous le voyez il est
aujourd'hui à Oslo en Norvège visite
surprise durant laquelle le président a
plaidé pour le maintien de l'aide
occidentale à son pays
écoutez pour ne pas perdre nos vies
notre société nos enfants et tous les
autres il nous faut bien sûr un
véritable bouclier de défense
solide des avions de l'artillerie tout
ce qui est
possible on en a besoin et bien sûr on
ne peut pas obtenir cela si le monde si
l'Europe ne sont pas unis autour de
l'Ukraine c'est pourquoi on ne peut pas
gagner sans
aide voilà voladimir zelensk qui pose le
débat à quelques heures du sommet
européen Alix lebourdon on vous retrouve
en direct de Bruxelles bonjour à vous
les enjeux sont énormes pour Kiev que ce
soit pour son adhésion à l'Union
européenne que pour le déblocage de la
nouvelle enveloppe
d'aide en effet c'est une grande partie
du soutien européen à l'Ukraine qui va
se jouer demain et après-demain à
Bruxelles lors de ce sommet il y a un
obstacle de taille c'est Victor Orban le
Premier ministre hongrois qui a été l'un
des seuls dirigeants à garder des liens
étroits avec le kremelin depuis le début
de la guerre en Ukraine alors
concrètement sur la table des 27 chef
d'État et de gouvernement demain et
après-demain on va trouver deux
questions cruciales liées à Raine
d'abord celle de l'ouverture des
négociations d'adhésion à l'Union
européenne vous savez que le pays a
obtenu officiellement le statut de
candidat il y a 18 mois mais la
prochaine étape c'est l'ouverture de ces
négociations d'adhésion et là et bien
Victor Orban menace de bloquer cette
décision qui doit se prendre à
l'unanimité en avançant l'argument que
l'Ukraine est un pays trop corrompu
l'autre question cruciale l'autre
décision he que menace de bloquer Victor
Orban c'est l'aide européenne de 50
milliards d'euros à l'Ukraine et là il
avance l'argument et bien que cette aide
ne ferait que prolonger cette guerre
alors en tout cas ici à Bruxelles on
attend aussi aujourd'hui une annonce de
la Commission européenne sur le
déblocage de fonds destiné à la Hongrie
bloqué jusqu'à présent pour des
questions d'État de droit alors même si
les officiels assurent que la date n'a
pas été choisie à dessin on imagine bien
qu'une telle annonce et bien pourrait
peser dans la balance sur ces véaux
brandis par Victor Orban